si el quinto él fue internado en
california él estaba ya en un evento
para su fundación y pues fue se estaba
sintiendo bastante débil fue hacerse
unos exámenes se le detectó una
infección urinaria que se contaminó por
todo su sistema sanguíneo entonces fue
internado lo que están diciendo los
médicos es que kenton está en activo
ticos que están en cuidados intensivos y
que está en esta unidad de cuidados
intensivos no tanto por el riesgo sino
más por la privacidad los médicos han
dicho que clinton está hablando con la
familia e incluso está caminando pero se
mantendrá en supervisión constante
clinton recordemos tiene 75 años y pues
ya había tenido varias operaciones en su
corazón pero los médicos han dicho que
esta infección urinaria que se ha
contagiado al sistema sanguíneo pues no
es tan riesgoso y que es común en
hombres de su edad